so is he that masculine guy that you're
like it does does your relationship with
your dad or like your family Dynamic did
that inform how you feel about male
female Dynamics in any way or does that
play a role
yeah of course of course it does like
thinking because I would say my dad is
like not red pill like he doesn't know
what the hell I mean he's been a little
bit red pill just because because of the
contest no because of me I'll be like
Dad you won't believe the stat I found
out today I love it I love it but yeah I
mean I really appreciated being grown up
with like two parents in the home and
especially the more I talk to people
that did it because it's like really sad
when I hear about their holidays and
stuff like there's so many people that
my mom would kill me if I didn't go home
for Christmas and then like I'm in
England and there's like other athletes
and they're like I don't know we're not
doing anything for Christmas I'm like
you're not doing anything for Christmas
yeah my mom would would strangle me